that played a very important role
obviously I come from a family where
both mom and dad was together in it and
I'd say it definitely had I'm from
Southland so you know so of course
especially London but it played a role
in having it that to kind of like as
much as you're not really listening
because you're growing up and as much as
we say our parents have a it's our
environment that kind of really guides
us and wants to tell us where we want to
go we hear a lot of what our parents say
in it but my parents weren't born to
understand so there's a lot of things
for me I never felt like they understood
because they're coming with their own
teachings and own upbringings because
they're not from here absolutely and
after as I got older and I have a child
myself and as I got older I appreciated
that and understood that a little bit
but it's it's more on the if you've got
parents that want to listen or if you
just got parents that's like no why I
say Goals kind of thing you know let me
just jump in yeah because like for me
that's the exact same thing but
obviously I was just my me and my mom in
it and my siblings right and I think a
lot of like first generation kids can
like relate to that whereas like you
know our parents come from wherever they
came from then they came to the UK and
then you know it's like they want to
raise their children like they're still
back home you're not back home it's not
the exactly they didn't have us over
there you had us here for a reason
is like I remember like growing up
getting into trouble you know people
want to try you bully you you know stuff
like that and then your mom's like read
your book read your yeah I'm saying and
it's not as simple as that but like
there's no formula in this book that's
gonna help me with this situation and
it's it's not it's I don't really blame
them because they don't know like yeah
but it's like they don't they're not
really fully equipped to give us the
advice because they're just thinking
well I'm just working my job I'm just
putting a roof over your head just shut
up and go to school you know what I'm
saying so that that is uh that is real
man no you definitely like I said you
definitely played a big part obviously a
man is still a man in it like
I learned from feeling I don't really
learn from hearing in it so like I said
a man still a man you still hear what
they say go out and do what you do and
then when you realize you're like oh so
that's why you said what you said in it
so but yeah I feel like as a dad it's a
bit very like he played a big role in my
life in it for sure and it's helped me
when I'm with my daughter but I'm a big
kid when it comes to my dog she's my
reason to just be a child in it so but
I'm I want to be present I'm present as
is because he was present as much as he
worked and whatnot he made sure he had
time for activities or whatever I was
getting up to to kind of like steer me
away from doing wrong because he's like
cool you've got an interest in this
let's run with it kind of thing
absolutely that makes sense absolutely
and like obviously growing up in because
I'm from South London as well so like I
was born in King's College Hospital
everyone everyone knows Denmark
I'm about bro I'm about yeah but what
I'm saying is that like obviously for
you like you because I had like a couple
friends that had their dad as well but
like you've obviously you you probably
have had loads of friends that you know
they didn't have no dad and what was
kind of like the the difference when you
compare your your situation to their
situation as as you know coming up
living where you lived I'll say the
difference was they'll probably be
outside more
if that makes sense like
how can I explain that properly
everything they're doing they've been
doing from early everything we found
cool back then to obviously as you grow
up and then you're like you know what
this ain't cool you don't really need to
be doing this and obviously we took the
longer way around trying to find a
shortcut if that makes sense but yeah I
feel like don't get twisted there were
some that would still they didn't have
no doubt at home but they were still
book smart and doing all of that stuff
but it's just you're you're out more
because
eight times out of ten your mum's
working umpteen amount of jobs and then
you're on the Block even if you're good
at school and a good child you're on a
block you ain't got nothing to do you've
got your friends outside and it's just
that guidance of a male in it and it
goes back to it as a man you need a man
your mom's going to teach you what your
mom can teach you but you still need a
man to teach you certain things same way
of a woman the dad can be around but
your mom's gonna have to teach you
certain things that your dad just can't
in it you know what I'm saying so I feel
like that's very important there in it
and yeah
yeah let's just say though outside more
though outside a bit earlier than I was
isn't it absolutely absolutely
um Auntie what do you think about it I
think I'm gonna get lost all right no
problem all right let's start from my
guy here what's going on what'd you
think about it and what was your your
situation growing up my situation
similar to you I just grew up with my
mum
didn't really know my dad's first sort
of
meeting I had was when I was 13 I got a
birthday card saying obviously I'm your
dad blah blah blah if you want to know
me he's got his demons whatever you know
I mean you can't blame people but
when you grow up without a dad your mom
has to sort of take them both roles
which Mom I'm done so that was a good
thing but like Kay said they can only
teach you so much
and the good thing for me is that's what
I found football
and obviously your friends outside
and it's not like Daddy Issues you know
what I mean but you just you're
constantly if you ain't got a dad I
don't I can't speak for everyone but for
myself I was like when I was at football
and I was a coach I would try and like
please that I wanted to be I wanted them
to watch me do this and then praise me
and you sort of look for that that
placement and it's just yeah it's just
it's difficult yeah no I relate to that
as well it's mad that I relate to
everyone anyway because I played uh I
played every sport in school everything
yeah at first I was a fat kid yeah
everyone not knowing me from back in the
day
and then I was I just threw into sports
the first one was Rugby Football
um Athletics like the weights that I've
fallen off then um what's it then
eventually I graduated to American
football and that um propelled me to go
and play in the States but um absolutely
I always kind of felt like you'd always
find that one coach that you you build
that Rapport that connection with and
it's like yeah I want I want to impress
them I want to make him proud that like
boom he's put investment in me time and
effort like you get what I'm saying and
yeah no yeah definitely
when you don't have a dad you kind of
look for that out there you get what I'm
saying but the the danger is
we've like you know us guys we played
Sports whatever other guys don't do that
they just look on the road on the street
for somebody and then that's when you
know you can get um kind of coerced into
doing things you know I'm not even gonna
go into it but you know things illegal
that you're not meant to be doing
because you're trying to impress the
older guy and he's telling you to go
here take this package here blah blah
blah and you know you know it just leads
to statistics that we'll we'll talk
about later so what else did you want to
say bro no it's like just adding what
you said obviously where I'm from South
London as well so
but like you said it can go either way
like you can find sport or you can go
down that road so but as a kid when
you've got no dad you're like when you
grow up like me now
like I want
I don't know like if I was looking for a
partner for example
and I'm looking for a girlfriend I want
her to have the whole stable family
because I want to be a part of it you
know I mean I want that Dad that I never
had but I want it that I don't know like
if I get a girlfriend I want a dad to
say you out mate that we're gonna go
watch the football we're going golf next
week and I think yeah that's that's what
I want now as an adult like I know what
I want obviously when you're a kid you
you ain't gotta say but I was lucky to
have my mum she was both you know I mean
my mum she's she's a great woman I'll
say one thing yeah it's like us guys
that didn't have a dad we we love our
moms like like anyone says oh your mom
it's a fight she can't say your mom to
us guys like I know it's guys that out
there that seem to not really they might
get upset but don't take it as deep but
we take it deep because the mom is our
mama dad is on everything in it like to
get them saying and you know it's a deep
horns but my question would be to you
man did you clock that now you're a man
some of the [ __ ] that your mum done
that you just lied because it was your
mum yeah absolutely absolutely well
we're gonna go into that all right we're
gonna go into that don't worry all right
I'm gonna move to the next guest yeah so
for me I grew up with my dad this is so
I grew up with my dad I'm close with my
dad I can say without my dad I wouldn't
be the woman I am today
um I advocate for men in general in this
Society I will say that growing up the
strength that your dad can give you as a
woman it allows you to navigate the
world in a different way so for example
with men I don't feel the need to argue
with them
about little things in relationships
um I think when I have issues I can go
to my dad he gives me a logical
explanation that takes me out of my
emotional state sometimes I'll call him
up like that and he'll just be like
think about the situation with a clearer
mind so think about it in such an
emotional way
um myself I have cerebral palsy so
having a disability growing up with a
disability I can say that my dad he
pushed me I did Sports
um there was nothing that any child was
doing that I couldn't do according to my
dad so that kind of gave me
the the power to have strength in my
ability no matter the situation
I think on the flip side
um situations that I've seen for myself
in a family unit I can empathize with
women as a woman and I can empathize
with men
from a woman's perspective
um and a lot of situations that I've
seen men go through I can't say I've
experienced it and I can't say I
understand it but I can respect the
response to it you get what I mean so I
think having a dad allowed me to have a
better understanding of men and for that
reason I don't feel the need to do a lot
of the things that women might do
because they might have not had a dad in
their life or a male figure
um I don't lead with my sexuality that's
one thing because I don't feel the need
to my dad always said you have to be
smart you have to be you know men can be
attracted to you physically for a period
of time but it's other things that will
keep them locked in absolutely and I
think that's what he helped me build my
I wouldn't say my personality but he
really embedded in me like be more than
your looks kind of thing
reach for what you want your goals
they're reachable you know what I mean
so I will say
um looking at
like my friends who might have not had
their dad in their life they'll come to
my house and my dad's like their Uncle
so they're integrated into my family and
the joy that it brought them so I would
say dads are important and for you guys
like you're talking about your stories
I've seen it I grew up in Edmonton in
North London so a lot of the young the
people I grew up with as a young woman
I've seen them struggle and battle with
things that I ins I wouldn't necessarily
battle with
so I do appreciate my dad and yeah I
would say there are downsides because
you experience other Dynamics between
parents you know that's natural but um
yeah I think having it having your dad
in your life like is important and as a
woman to even if you're a single mother
I would advise every woman unless the
guy is like alcoholic drug use or
whatever do not stop your children from
seeing their dad because not about you
it's about your kids
you're kind of denying them an
experience
yeah so yeah I had so many questions for
you while I was talking yeah
yeah so I've got one give you a chance
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible